welcome back to the David Pakman show
again I'm obviously not david pakman
David is away he will be back tomorrow
thanks for letting me fill in David and
speak to your audience about all the
news and I want to start with the
rhetorical question if you would how
many times can Donald Trump lie to the
American people and get away with it he
we don't have an instance of him
perjuring himself while he's under under
you know giving sworn testimony or
testifying you know before the Senate
which I know he would never do are
speaking to the FBI but Republicans have
made the case with Bill Clinton that
lying to America is a very serious issue
and the wall street journal has just
released another report illustrating
that Donald Trump is has lied to America
yet again I want to read a little bit
from the article quote President Trump
personally directed an effort in
February to stop stormy Daniels from
publicly describing an alleged sexual
encounter with mr. Trump people with
people familiar with the event say in a
phone call mr. Trump instructed his then
lawyer Michael Cohen to speak to seek a
restraining order against the former
adults film actress whose real name is
Stephanie Clifford through a
confidential arbitration proceeding one
of the people said okay Trump and Cohen
had learned shortly before that mr.
Clifford Miss Clifford Rather was
considering giving a media interview
about her alleged relationship with mr.
Trump despite having signed in October
2016 non-disclosure agreement this last
paragraph is important mr. Trump told
mr. Cohen to coordinate the legal
response with Eric Trump one of the
president's sons and another outside
lawyer who had represented mr. Trump and
the Trump Organization in other matters
people the people said so we have
multiple lies in here the President of
the United States said that he had no
knowledge of these things that were
going on had no to attempted to did not
attempt to sway stormy Daniels one way
or the other the the specific lie here
is that regarding to the Trump
Organization involve
mint with store McDaniels Eric Trump is
now running the organization for his
father and one of the attorneys involved
represented the Trump Organization now
the Wall Street Journal did report that
the law firm for the attorney stated
that that that he did this the attorney
I don't know if it's a woman or a man
did this on their own accord and not
associated with the Trump Organization
however the ties are too close and
whether that makes a difference in terms
of substantively in terms of the
narrative in terms of exposing any new
facts or any new truths I mean we all
knew Donald Trump is a liar that's
that's that remains to be seen I how
significant this story is in and of
itself that remains to be seen but it's
yet again another example of Donald
Trump lying to America and when
Republicans have set the standard with
the Kenneth Starr investigation back in
the 90s late 90s they set the standard
that one lie to America is enough for
impeachment proceedings you you have to
really ask yourself when is enough
enough
well I've answered the Cask myself the
question and I've answered the question
for myself
here's the thing and I don't know if
I've ever discussed this with with
David's audience but I discussed this
all the time with my audience pointing
out the hypocrisy of Republicans is is
point less it absolutely is point less
because they thrive on hypocrisy they
absolutely will commence impeachment
proceedings over Bill Clinton's lie and
we will be sitting with two three
hundred lies that will actually were me
into the thousands well over a thousand
at least lies of Donald Trump and we're
not even bat an eye and if you want to
point out the difference between relying
under oath and lying in general fine and
and that's a fair that's a fair
observation but the fact of the matter
remains is that the Republican Party
absolutely will hold Democrats and
progressives to a standard that they
will never hold
selves to they have no intention of
holding themselves to that standard
because it gives them a political
advantage it's called the asymmetrical
political battle and in this
asymmetrical political war the people
who try to abide by decorum people who
tried to abide by norms and institutions
the people who tried to abide by the
rules are always at a disadvantage to
the people who are willing to blow this
entire thing to hell and the Republican
Party has demonstrated that time and
again they are willing to break every
rule to destroy every institution to
renege on every regime to do anything
they will rewrite history they will look
at you in the face and call you a
hypocrite and then two seconds later be
hypocritical themselves they will do
anything and everything for a single
political win not the big win but a
single political win and Democrats are
still trying to hold themselves to some
notions of decorum of institutional
norms and civility and in this
asymmetrical fight the Democrats will
always lose which they have been for a
very long time
I think we we we fooled ourselves with
Obama's victory thinking that we made
real big strides the the the fact of the
matter is Obama's victory is a bit of an
anomaly in terms of American history
obviously but recent history the era of
Newt Gingrich I was reading I don't know
who I was reading I don't know which
article is reading it and possibly no I
do know the the guy that wrote the book
and I can't think of his name it's time
to fight dirty I think I have the book
back here anyway he was on he was on
with David Pakman a few weeks ago and he
pointed out that the best place to trace
this to would be Newt Gingrich and so in
this era of Newt Gingrich's
scorched earth politics where you lie to
everyone's faces but then you try to
hold other people to the absolute most
pedantic interpretation of the truth
right that creates an asymmetrical fight
that Democrat
cannot win so to my rhetorical question
how many times can Trump lie to America
and get away with it as many times as he
wants to so long as Republicans are in
power